este es uno de los campos gestionados
por los kurdos en el noreste de Siria
donde las enfermedades y la malnutrición
son comunes dos mujeres francesas están
retenidas aquí y quieren volver a casa
con sus hijos dejaron Francia para estar
con sus parejas que Son miembros del
autodenominado estado islámico Y hasta
ahora el gobierno francés ha rechazado
sus peticiones el miércoles el tribunal
europeo de Derechos Humanos intervino
dictaminando que Francia había violado
sus derechos a entrar en el territorio
del Estado del que son nacionales
añadiendo que la solicitudes deben ser
procesadas lo antes posible como
reacciona la sentencia el gobierno
francés dijo que ha terminado con su
política caso por caso de devolver a los
niños a Francia sin sus madres
la decisión lo hemos esperado a que
avance la decisión del tribunal europeo
de Derechos Humanos porque este verano
en julio Francia procedió a repatriar a
16 mujeres que estaban en moleste de
Siria y a una treintena de niños
el caso fue presentado por los padres de
las mujeres que dicen que sus hijas y
nietos están retenidos en uno de los
varios campamentos gestionados por los
kurdos en el nordeste donde están siendo
maltratados
Espero que no pasen otro invierno allí
porque mi nieto tiene tres años y medio
es lo único que ha conocido es el único
que tengo tengo cuatro hijos solo tengo
un nieto Me encantaría tenerlo con
nosotros
los grupos Defensores de los Derechos
Humanos señalan que unas 75 mujeres y
160 niños franceses permanecen en los
campos París lleva tiempo argumentando
que los ciudadanos con conexiones con
redes radicales en Siria e Irak
supondrían un riesgo para la seguridad
si volvieran al país